monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires européennes cher Pierre
Alexandre bienvenue ici dans cette dans
cette commission deux étages plus bas
que que la tienne messieurs les
ministres plinit potentière mes chers
collègues tout d'abord je me permets de
vous adresser à ceux que j'ai pas encore
vu mes meilleurs vux pour l'année 2024
puisque vous le savez nous étions pour
la semaine dernière en déplacement en
Afrique justement au Nigéria et en en
Éthiopie avec trois de de nos collègues
annapic ici présente Benoît Borda et
François piicmal déplacement d'ailleurs
extrêmement intéressant puisque non
seulement on a pu travailler la relation
bilatérale avec ces pays mais comme vous
le savez par ailleurs
le le Nigéria accueille le siège de la
CDAO et l'Éthiopie accueille le siège de
l'Union africaine donc on a pu avoir
également avoir une dimension régionale
et continentale grâce à ce déplacement
je remercie le président de la
commission des affaires européennes
Pierre Alexandre Anglade pour avoir
accepté que sa commission se joigne à la
notre pour cette audition commune sur
les politiques africaines de nos
principaux partenaires européens nous
sommes convaincus que une partie de
l'avenir de l'Europe se jouera en partie
dans sa relation avec le continent
africain et notamment sur les domaines
sécuritaires et effectivement la semaine
dernière dans notre dans nos échanges
avec les responsables de l'Union
africaine il a beaucoup été question de
l'Union
européenne dans ce partenariat qui est
qui est mis en place et qui doit sans
cesse se renouveler bien entendu il y a
la coopération au niveau continental
mais beaucoup relèvent de la compétence
des États-membres de l'Union européenne
et nous avons le plaisir aujourd'hui
d'accueillir le docteur Martin chafford
ministre PL potentiire de l'ambassade
d'Allemagne en France bienvenue monsieur
Antonio casquio ministre PL potentière
de à l'ambassade d'Italie en France
bienvenue également et Monsieur Benjamin
saoul ministre conseiller aux affaires
étrangères et stratégiques intérieures
et de justice à l'ambassade de Royaume
Uni en France euh bienvenue également je
souigne que vous avez accepté tous les
trois de vous exprimer en français et je
vous en remerci très vivement en ces
temps où la politique française menée en
Afrique fait l'objet de nombreuses
réflexions et débats nous avons pensé
nécessaire de mieux connaître et
comprendre les grandes orientations de
la politique africaine de vos pays
respectifs et de mettre en exer de
similitude des différences afin
éventuellement d'en tirer des des leçons
pour voir comment mieux coopérer
ensemble vos trois pays accordent chacun
une place importante à l'Afrique
l'Allemagne a adopté l'an dernier une
nouvelle stratégie pour le continent
africain et ce sera d'ailleurs un des
sujets de discussion de la commission
qui se déplacera à Berlin dès dimanche
soir avec d'ailleurs SEP sénateurs nous
serons h sénateurs même nous serons huit
sénateurs se députés à la rencontre avec
au Bundestag avec nos nos homologues euh
l'Italie a désigné pour sa part la cante
de l'Afrique comme une priorité euh lors
de la conférence des nations- Unies sur
la Corne de l'Afrique qui s'est tenu à
Rome en mai dernier et d'ailleurs j'ai
eu l'occasion de constater avec mes
collèg l'importance accordée à la
présence italienne en Éthiopie euh lors
de notre déplacement la semaine dernière
et je crois que notre commission se
rendra également à Rome euh de mémoire
en en février dans dans quelques
semaines enfin concernant le Royaume-Uni
j'ai bien noté que le premier dirigeant
étranger reçu en visite officielle par
le roi Charles II fut symboliquement le
président sudaque africain Cyril
ramafosa et que Londres accueillera une
grande conférence Royaume-Uni Afrique
sur l'investissement en 2024 et mes
chers collègues vous vous souvenez que
l'an dernier nous avions eu l'occasion
de nous rendre à Londres que nous avions
même auditionné mon homologue l'an
dernier Tobias Elwood au sein même de de
cette commission et que nous comptons
bien en 2024 relancer cette ces
relations interparlementaire sachant
qu'il y a eu des des changements à la
tête de de la Commission du de défense
britannique avant que vous preniez la
parole messieurs je cède désormais la
parole au président Anglade qui va
également nous dire quelques mots merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président merci de
d'associer la commission des affaires
européennes à la réunion de de ce jour
parce que je je crois effectivement
important que nous puissions avoir cet
échange croisé tant la dimension
européenne est devenue aussi centrale
dans la politique africaine et et dans
les circonstances actuelles de de guerre
à haute intensité sur le continent
européen la crise majeure que nous
connaissons au Proche Orient je crois
que l'Afrique ne doit évidemment pas
passer au second plan de notre politique
nationale mais évidemment des des enjeux
européens et les enjeux de sécurité sont
liés à ce continent sont évidemment
considérables CIS que la boussole
stratégique adoptée par l'Union
européenne en mars 2022 en particulier
dans la
zone en Libye en sel en Afrique centrale
viennent viennent le rappeler avec des
risques terroristes croissants avec une
politique migratoire qui est également
complexe et et c'est évidemment au
niveau européen avec nos partenaires que
nous pourrons le le régler je pense
aussi à la stabilité dans le Golfe de
Guinée dans la Corne de l'Afrique dans
le canal du Mozambique qui constitue
également un impératif de sécurité
majeur pour l'Union européenne et
l'Union européenne déploie actuellement
6 missions PSDC sur le continent
africain la politique européenne
vis-à-vis de l'Afrique c'est aussi une
politique de de développement pour
l'Union européenne qui maintient une
relation très complète avec 47 accords
de partenariat économique un dialogue
régulier entre l'Union européenne et
l'Union africaine et une coopération
ambitieuse dans de multiples domaines et
donc c'est sur tous ces sujets que nous
aurons aussi à débattre et à discuter
aujourd'hui donc je ne serai pas plus
long et je souhaite que nous puissions
avoir un échange nourri et je vous
remercie encore monsieur le Président de
cette initiative qui me semble important
de pouvoir avoir des échanges croisés
entre nos deux commissions merci
monsieur le Président nous allons
désormais donner la parole à nos invités
monsieur le ministre plin potentière
docteur Martin chafford vous avez la
parole Messieurs les Présidents Mesdames
et Messieurs les les députés merci de
cette de cette invitation nous sommes 2
jours après cette belle journée
franco-allemande que nous célébrons
chaque année le 22 janvier et cette
année c'était un moment spécial que
votre président s'est rendu à Berlin
pour tenir un discours en allemand et je
suis sûr que son allemand va être un
petit peu mieux que mon français
aujourd'hui donc je m'excuse dès le
début de toutes les fautes grammaticales
et autres que j'ai que je vais connaître
monsieur le Président vous avez dit tout
à l'heure que vous allez vous déplacer à
Berlin bientôt avec toute votre
commission aussi avec vos collègues les
sénateurs et sénatrices tout ça comme
cette invitation euh de à notre part
aujourd'hui je crois que ça c'est
l'expression euh de votre volonté à un
partenariat approfondi euh et une
expression de l'amitié entre la France
et l'Allemagne aussi en ce qui concerne
toute
affaire Afri africaine pour moi c'est un
plaisir
particulier de parler avec vous sur
l'Afrique parce que moi j'ai passé 8 ans
de ma vie et 8 ans de ma vie
professionnel sur ce beau continent et
je vous dis en toute sincérité que très
souvent dans le cadre de mon travail
récemment en Afrique du Sud c'était
vraiment main dans la main avec nos
partenaires collègues et amis français
sur sur place donc permettez-moi de
commencer avec quelques observations
préliminaires en guise d'introduction
j'aimerais bien vous vous vous vous dire
qu'en tant que continent voisin l'Europe
et l'Afrique sont éatement liés sur les
plans économiques politiques culturels
et historique contenu de de la
démographie et des facteurs économiques
l'importance du continent africain dans
le monde et pour nous les Européens est
une évidence d'ici 2050 un quart de la
population mondiale vivra en Afrique
soit presque quatre fois plus qu'en
Europe c'est pourquoi l'Afrique est
considéré non pas comme un continent du
futur mais peut-être le continent du
futur et les pays les pays africains
sont évidemment déjà des acteurs
importants sur la scène internationale
l'action de l'Afrique du Sud devant la
Cour internationale de Justice récemment
à l'égard euh d'un présumé
génucide commis par l'Israël on est une
une évidence onê la preuve dans ce
contexte le gouvernement fédéral
allemand s'est doté déjà en 2014 des
lignes directrices pour sa politique
vis-à-vis de l'Afrique leur dernière
édition date de 2019 et une mise en une
mise mise à jour est en cours sous le
leadership du ministère des Affaires
étrangères nous sommes convaincus que
nous ne pourrons relever les défis de
notre époque qu'on agissons avec nos
partenaires africains permettez-moi
alors de de présenter dans le bref tant
que que j'ai
à à ma disposition notre politique
africain en trois parties comme il faut
dans un pays cartésien donc je vais
commencer en première partie pour parler
en quelques mots sur notre politique sur
le climat et l'énergie deuxièmement sur
la croissance économique et la lutte
contre de pauvreté et finalement et
troisièmement peut-être plus intéressant
pour vous encore sur la paix la
stabilité et la sécurité alors premier
point climat et énergie le premier défi
majeur concerne le réchauffement
climatique et l'approvisionnement
énergétique en Afrique la pénie la
pénuie d'énergie touche encore
aujourd'hui près de la moitié de la
population du continent une situation
qui doit changer au plus vite
parallèlement le continent africain est
particulièrement touché par les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
il est donc dans l'intérêt de tous au
sens littéral que les objectifs fixés
dans l'accord de Paris soit respecté
l'Allemagne a lancé euh des partenariats
sur les sujets d'énergie et le climat
avec une douzaine de pays africains
jusqu'à aujourd'hui en 2022 un/ers de
notre budget de politique climatique à
l'étranger soit un euh 1liard 700
millions 1.73 milliards d'euros est allé
à des pays africains dans le cadre de la
COP 26 nous avons conclu un partenariat
pour une transition énergitique juste
jetp comme ça se dit en anglais avec
l'Afrique du Sud et je peux vous dire
que avec mon mon collègue l'ambassadeur
de France en Afrique du Sud on était
vraiment
euh au début de T c proc toutes ces
procédures et on a fait en sorte que ça
aboutit avec un tel résultat en
franco-allemand
euh en juin 2023 un partenariat
similaire été conclu avec le Sénégal
lors du sommet de Paris pour un nouveau
Pact financier l'Afrique n'est pas
uniquement récipient d'aide dans ce
secteur à notre avis elle dispose d'un
grand potentiel pour surmonter le défi
du réchauffement climatique et du besoin
des sources énergétiques aussi pour nous
en Europe par exemple dans l'énergie
solaire et l'hydrogène verte et des
projets très concret par exemple avec la
avec la Namibie ont déjà ont déjà
commencé elle peut donc jouer un rôle
important dans la transition énergétique
opérée en Europe et en Allemagne comme
le chancelier schz l'a annoncé en
novembre dernier l'Allemagne fournira 4
million d'euros d'ici 2030 à
l'initiative Afrique Union européenne
pour l' ég verte afin de valoriser
l'immense potentiel de cette coopération
entre l'Afrique et l'Union européenne 2è
point l'agenda
2030 pour la croissance économique et la
lutte contre la pauvreté notre 2ème défi
principal que nous partageons consiste à
atteindre les objectifs de développement
durable de l'agenda 2030 des Nations
Unies à cet égard il reste beaucoup à
faire en Afrique comme ailleurs et
surtout dans la lutte contre la pauvreté
la pandémie de covid et la guerre
d'agression russe contre l'ouraine ainsi
que leurs conséquences ont rendu cette
tâche encore plus difficile l'Allemagne
soutient avec détermination une
transformation sociale et écologique des
systèmes économiques en Afrique afin de
relever ces défis nous y travaillons par
le biais de notre action diplomatique à
l'échelle bilatérale je vous rappelle
que l'Allemagne dispose de 44 ambassades
sur le continent africain européenne et
multilatérale ainsi que dans le cadre de
notre coopération pour le développement
l'aide au développement seulle ne
pourrait pas permettre de relever ces
défis à notre avis il faut davantage
d'investissements publics mais aussi des
investissements du secteur privé qui
permettent de construire des
infrastructures modernes et générant peu
d'émissions dans le secteur de de
l'énergie de la santé et des transports
par exemple c'est une vision que nous
partageons avec la France pour faciliter
ces invest ement surtout du secteur
privé qui nécessite souvent des réformes
dans les pays partenaires l'Allemagne a
lancé un
un instrument de coopération
multilatérale excusez-moi en 2017 le
programme G20 compact with Africa l'idée
est d'identifier les pays africains les
plus aptes à absorber des
investissements privé en ajustant les
conditions d'accueil de ces fonds pour
générer la de la croissance de la
croissance le dernier sommet a eu lieu
le 20 novembre 2023 à Berlin en présence
de 28 délégations et 700 participants y
compris le président de la République
française 3è partie la paix la stabilité
et la sécurité le troisème et dernier
défi que j'aimerais évoquer avec vous
est en quelque sorte un préalable pour
pouvoir relever les deux premiers je
veux parler de la paix et de la
stabilité sans stabilité les
perspectives de croissance de respect
des droits humains et et d'adaption des
mesures écologiques ne sont
qu'éphémè notre ministère des Affaires
étrangères madame Annalena berbock est
justement le moment où nous parlons ici
à Paris en Afrique de l'Est eu elle est
à Djibouti aujourd'hui demain au Kenya
et vendredi euh dans le sud dans le Sud
soudin lors de ces entretiens sur place
il sera notamment question des moyens de
mieux coordonner les initiatives
internationales et européenes de
médiation pour mettre fin au combat au
soudain une région particulièrement
importante en en Afrique le Sahel est
bouleversé par l'instabilité et par des
couts d'État comme vous le savez tous
les pays du Sahel sont confrontés à
d'immenses défis allant des effets de
changement climatique à la croissance
démographique rapide associé à la
pénurie des ressources en passant par le
terisme transfrontalier et de la
criminalité organisée nous souhaitons
vivement une stabilisation de la région
car ce que se passe au Sahel aura tôt et
tôt ou tard des répercussions sur nous
en Europe et nous sommes prête à nous y
mettre il faut faut un nouveau départ et
nous aimerons nous aimerions participer
à la création de celui-ci ensemble avec
nos partenaires européens notamment
NOTAM notamment la France ainsi que
d'autres partenaires internationau et
régionaux peut-être il a ce moment
difficile pour toute la région et pour
nous nos relations avec le Salel
peut-être considéré aussi comme une
opportunité d'une approche commune avec
un agenda agréé qui focalise sur le
développement durable dans un sens large
du terme nous restons donc engagés au
Sahel à travers l'aide humanitaire les
mesures de stabilisation et la
coopération au développement nous
voulons nous attaquer aux causes
profondes des conflits et aider les
populations du Sahel à devenir plus
résistantes au terrorisme et à la
criminalité organisé parallèlement nous
essayons d'éviter que l'instabilité du
sel ne se propage au pays voisin c'est
dans ce contexte que nous aidons la
Mauritanie et les États du Golfe de
Guinée à stabiliser leur région
frontalière et à réformer leur secteur
de sécurité le leadership africain et
les approches fondées sur des principe
le développement économique la bonne
gouvernance l'État de droit sont
essentiels dans ce processus donc en
conclusion pour nous il est clair que
nous nous retrouvons pris dans une
compétition stratégique à l'échelle
mondiale une chose et sûr mesdames et
messieurs les députés un partenariat
avec la Russie n'est pas une voie pour
les pays africains qui promet de la paix
de la stabilité et encore moins de la
démocratie et de la croissance
économique nous européens devront donc
rester engagés dans la dans la région et
mieux communiquer nos nos efforts il
faut agir ensemble avec une stratégie
commune et mettre notre poid économique
nos liens culturels et historiques et
nos partenariats politiques au profit
d'un développement propre de notre
continent voisin avec lequel nous sommes
aussi dans une communauté de destin en
conclusion permettez-moi de vous assurer
de la volonté forte du gouvernement
allemand à participer dans un effort
commun européen d'établissement d'une
approche nouvelle et commune de l'Union
européenne les contacts bilatéraux et
pour parler récent ont été prometteur
dans ce sens donc je suis résolument
optimiste que nous
que que nous puissions parvenir à un
partenariat entre l'Europe et
l'Afrique qui respecte nos valeurs qui
correspond aux intérêts de tous les
participants des deux côtés de la
Méditerranée et qui contribu au
bien-être à la stabilité et sécurité
chez nous en Europe et en Afrique je
vous remercie de votre attention merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre potenti la
parole est désormais Antonio casquio
pour l'Italie
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs merci de de cette
opportunité de de de parler d'un sujet
qui est central pour la politique
étrangère italienne en fait c'est veà
dire la l'Afrique et notre approche à
l'Afrique ça ne va pas ne va pas vous
surprendre mais beaucoup de choses que
je veux dire sont absolument en ligne
avec ce que mon collègue allemand vient
de dire surtout quand il s'agit je de la
nécessité d'une approche qui implique
toute l'Union européenne et toutes les a
tous les les acteurs qui sont aussi en
dehors de de l'Union européenne et qui
partagent nos nos valeurs nos principes
notre vision de relation internationales
pour faire face à des défis qui ont une
échelle qu'on peut pas euh traiter à
niveau dans dans dans single de pays
l'Afrique est depuis toujours une
priorité pour la politique étrangère
italienne en raison de lien historique
géographique économique et sociaux qui
qui font de mon pays un pont naturel
comme nous l'aimons dire entre l'Europe
et le continent africain et ce n'est pas
par hasard que l'Afrique est aussi une
des priorités de notre présidence du G7
en 2024 justement en raison de la
proximité géographique et de l'intensité
de la nation on sait bien que tout ce
qui arrive en Afrique a des
répercussions immédiates sur l'Italie
euh pour rappeler seulement les exemples
les plus évidents on l'a vu en 2011 avec
la chute de Gaddafi en Libye on l'a vu
dans les derniers années avec les crises
migratoires qui ont frappé
l'Europe pour ce qui concerne euh
relation avec l'Afrique les liens les
plus étroits sont évidemment avec les
pays de l'Afrique du Nord qui souffent
la Méditerranée et avec les pays de la
Corne de l'Afrique comme le rappelait
monsieur le Président pour des raisons
historiques liées à notre histoire
coloniale et dans les dernières années
on a développé des liens toujours plus
étroits aussi avec les pays du Sahel
avec une une action qui est liée à notre
perception du sel comme une région
stratégique pour l'Italie et pour
l'Europe nous avons aussi des relations
très étroites avec les pays de l'Afrique
centrale et australe australe comme le
Kenya l'Angola l'Afrique du Sud et les
Mozambiques où nous sommes engagés dans
ce moment avec aussi dans la mission
européenne de soutiens aux autorités euh
du Mozambique et où la médiation
soutenue par l'Italie a eu un rôle
important pour arriver à la signature en
1992 à Rome des accords qui ont mis fin
à la guerre civile en général donc nous
sommes convaincus qu'il sera une grave
erreur de nous désintéresser de
l'Afrique ce qui est arrivé au Sahel
dernièrement mais aussi dans d'autres
régions de l'Afrique pendant les
dernières années nous a montré que dès
qu'il y a un vide il y a immédiatement
des acteurs qui sont prêts à le remplir
et ces acteurs ne sont pas forcément
animés par les meilleurs intention
envers l'Europe nos valeurs et nos
intérêts et comme le disait mon collègue
éalement les solutions qu'il propose ne
sont pas forcément les meilleur pour les
pays africains non plus et là aussi je
suis absolument en ligne avec ce que
Martin venit de dire nous parlons d'un
continent dont l'importance stratégique
est tout à fait évident il y a
aujourd'hui en fait en 2 milliards de
personnes ce seront 2,5 milliards d'ici
2050 et il y aura un un numéro un
chiffre en nombre de travaillés qui
pourrait passer à 1,1 milliard de
personnes c'est-à-dire plus que la Chine
et pour permettre à ces à ces personnes
de avoir une vie digne ce veut dire et
de de du travail et tout ça veut dire
assurer une croissance économique qui
serait au moins de 6 7 % par an donc
c'est pas un défi négligeable l'impact
des changements climatiques on l'a déjà
rappelé est en train de frapper de
manière particulièrement sévère les
continents africains avec des
conséquences très dures aussi sur le
plan économique social et politique des
conséquences qui risquent d'exacerber
les cycles d'instabilité et tout cela
risque d'alimenter ultérieurement les
flux migratoires internes et externes au
continents à ainsi que l'attractivité
disons de trafic illicite de la
propagande extrémiste il nous impose
donc un effort conjoint et massif pour
accompagner le développement de
l'Afrique et assurer la stabilité une
stabilité qu'on ne pourra assurer
seulement avec notre soutien dans le
domaines de la gouvernance défense et de
la sécurité même si ce soutiens restent
bien entendu indispensable face à des
gouvernements qui fatiguent à imposer
leur autorités sur leur territoire pour
toutes ces raisons
l'Italie est engagée dans le
développement d'un partenariat
stratégique paritaire et équitable pour
promouvoir un développement commun
durable dans les trois dimensions
environnementales sociales et économique
respectueux des cultures et des
traditions de chacun tout en restant
fidèle à nos principes et valeurs
partagées c'est ce qu'on appelait en
Italie les PL matille du nom d'en
rcoateille ancien fondateur du groupe
énergétique italien en est l'un des
personnages symboles de la coopération
de l'amitié entre l'Italie et l'Afrique
don les lignes seront illustrées et
discuté en occasion du premier sommet
Italie Afrique qui se tiendra à Rome le
28 et 29 janvier donc la semain prochain
les plan contient six domaines
opérationnel la coopération au
développement les partenariats
économiques les fluxes migratoires
développement et transition verte paix
et sécurité les partenariat culturel
dans ces cadres on essaiera de
travailler de manière organique et
cohérente sur plusieurs lignes d'action
donc la promotion des exportations et
des investissements l'éducation et la
formation professionnelle la Recherche
et Innovation l'espace la santé
l'agriculture et la sécurité alimentaire
l'approvisionnement à l'exploitation
durable des ressources la lutte
changement climatique les
infrastructures les soutiens aux
entreprises avec une attention
particulière aux PM aux jeunes et aux
femmes le tourisme les échanges
culturels la lutte à la migration
illégale je voudrais en particulier
attirer votre attention sur quelques
secteurs d'action qui ont d'un notre
vision une importance prioritaire
c'est-à-dire la réalisation
d'infrastructure de qualité qui sera
emmené en ligne avec les global Gateway
de l'Union européenne et la par chez les
partenariats du G7 pour la
l'infrastructure globale
l'infrastructure et l'investissement
global une initiative du G7 allemand de
2022 l'énergie
et là encore je fais écho à ce que mon
collègue allemand venit de dire avec une
attention particulière à la positiontion
des sources renouvelables inclu le
développement de biocarburant et à la
réalisation de réseau de distribution et
des solutions pour l'accumulation de
l'énergie une une chose dont l'Afrique a
vraiment besoin nous sommes en fait
convaincu qu'une meilleure intégration
entre l'Europe et l'Afrique
bénéficierait les deux et voulons
soutenir la production d'hydrogène vert
à partir des sources renouvelbles en
mettant l'Italie à disposition comme hub
de la distribution vers l'Europe en
exploitant aussi si la le réseau de
gazoduc existant l'extraction des
matières premières critiques de manière
durable par exemple en développant le
recyclage et les mines urbaines les
contrasts au changement climatique et là
on a intention de dier une partie
importante du fond italien pour le
climat qui a une dotation de 4 milliards
d'euros à la coopération avec l'Afrique
la lutte à la migration illégale par les
biais d'un approche holistique qui
unisse l'aide au développement
économique la formation professionnelle
la réalisation de Canau efficace d'
migration légale le gouvernement italien
a prévu 452000 accès en 3 ans pour les
migrants professionnalisé les
développement de la migration circulaire
la conclusion d'accord de réadmission
avec les pays d'origine et les soutient
aux activités de contrôle et de
répression de la migration illégale en
les accompagnant avec des activités de
formation qui garantissent aussi le
respect des droits humaines et des
libertés fondamentales et en général à
propos d'migration mais en général pour
notre politique envers l'Afrique je
voudrais aussi rappeler que l'Italie à
Bruxelles a toujours pleaidé pour avoir
davantage de fonds europé destinés au
partenariat avec l'Afrique et dans les
secteurs migratoires avec les pays
d'origine et de transit de flux
migratoire ces partenariats sont de not
point de vue lestion les plus efficaces
pour essayer de réduire la migration
illégale et mieux encadrer la migration
légale
euh cela dit
en voulant traiter spécifiquement des
questions liées à la sécurité et la
stabilité de
l'Afrique là aussi on partage la
considération qu'il faut éviter un
dérapage de l'Afrique interne de
sécurité et pour ça l'Italie est
particulièrement engagé en Afrique dans
ce secteur par les BIA des missions
militaires et civiles de soutien aux
autorités locales on est bien consent
comme je disais tout à l'heure du défi
que représente la firirmation de
l'autorité de l'État sur des territoires
très étendus et où survivent souvent des
logiques tribales face à une menace
extrémiste qui prospère aussi en raison
des carences de l'État et des conditions
économiques difficiles les focus
géographiques de notre rtion et les SEL
évidemment qui représente pour nous la
porte de l'Europe et par où passe tous
les trafics illégaux qui risquent de
mettre en danger la stabilité et la
sécurité de notre continent mais aussi
la Corne de l'Afrique et l'Afrique du
Nord en général très brivement nous
sommes engagés dans des missions en
titre national en Libye avec 200 unités
en nigerre avec une mission dont les
activités ont été évidemment interrompu
suite au coups d'État en Somalie euh
avec 115 unités nous avons une base
opérationnelle au Djibouti on avait
autorisé une mission de 50 unités au
Burkina Faso qui n'a étéit jamais
opérationnalisé suite au coup d'État et
nous soms présent dans beaucoup
d'émissions opération multilatéral etutm
Somalie et au Cap Somalie etutm
Mozambique Atalanta évidemment et nous
participons à activité de contrastes à
la piraterie dans le golfes de
Guinée nous attribuons aussi beaucoup
d'importance au rôle que l'OTAN peut
jouer sur son fling sud nous sommes
convaincus que notre approche à la
sécurité euroatlantique doit s'inscrire
dans une vision à 360°gr la sécurité et
la stabilité de la région sont liés
d'une manière étroite à ce qui se passe
dans son voisinage et en particulier il
nous semble essentiel que l'OTAN
développe une stratégie d'engagement
avec les pays africain dans la dimension
de la sécurité coopérative nous
soutenons donc avec conviction le
travail du groupe d'experts sur les
flanc méridional encore je me permets de
citer mon collègue allemand pour dire
qu'on est absolument absolument d'accord
sur le fait que avoir une guerre sur le
continents européens ne doit pas nous
faire oublier qu'il y a des questions de
sécurité qu'il faut continuer de traités
auquel il faut continuer de faire face
en Afrique parce que les Oubliés seraiit
une erreur
finalement je profite aussi de cette
occasion pour rappeler l'excellente
coopération que nous avons toujours
entretenue avec la France avec qui nous
partageons une vision globale très
proche des enjeux en Afrique et avec qui
nous partageons aussi les mêmes intérêts
et les mêmes soucis pour le
développement la sécurité et la
stabilité du continent africain c'est
une priorité stratégique que et qui est
clairement souligné aux articles 1 du
traité du kinal et de la feuille de
route pour la mise en œuvre du trité de
keinard je veux rappeler à ces propos
que l'Italie avait mis à disposition de
la Task Force d'akuba 200 unités et h
hélicoptères pour lesvacuation médical
et que nous soutenons par exemple les
activités des écoles nationales la
vocation régionale française en Afrique
on vient de financer avec une
contribution de 620000 € l'école
d'Abidjan et avant les cûps à Niamé on
était en train de travailler ensemble la
France et l'Italie au projet d'école
pour la gestion coordonné des frontières
plus en général nous sommes absolument
convaincus que aucun d'entre nous nous à
même seul de résoudre de faire face au
défis que que que l'Afrique nous propose
donc il est essentiel de travailler dans
le cadre de l'Union européenne de l'OTAN
du G7 et avec nos partenaires hors de
l'Union Européenne qu'on le Royaume-Uni
pour trouver des des solutions
conjointes merci merci ministre monsieur
le ministre plin Potentier la parole est
désormais pour le Royaume-Uni à Benjamin
saoul merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président ou peut-être Messieurs les
Présidents
euh mesdames messieurs les députés euh
mesdames Messieurs les administrateurs
de la
commission chers collègues je vous
remercie tout d'abord pour cette
invitation aujourd'hui je suis Benjamin
saoul le ministre conseiller à
l'ambassade du
Royaume-Uni et je tiens tout d'abord à à
souligner l'importance pour nous de la
relation défense franco-britannique dans
le cadre de des accords de l house que
vous connaissez bien et dans ce cadre
aussi de souligner l'importance de de
votre relation en tant que comité de
défense à la assemblée avec le defense
sect commit du House of Commons présidé
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président par toaswood c'est une
relation qui est importante pour nous
sur le plan parlementaire et pour
renforcer le le rôle démocratique que
vous avez en tant qu'assemblée en tant
que comité dans le la supervision de la
de la la politique française le le même
rôle évidemment joué par par le le
Select commite du Parlement britannique
donc je je vais vous présenter
brièvement les grandes lignes
de la politique euh euh britannique en
Afrique je vais commencer par quelques
points de contexte et puis bien
évidemment comme comme mon collèg
allement une présentation ensuite en
trois parties pour vous vous présenter
les objectifs du Royaume-Uni en Afrique
notre partenariat avec la France et nos
autres partenaires internationaux pour
progresser notre coopération en Afrique
et puis finalement notre soutien pour la
démocratie et la gouvernance en Afrique
qui est évidemment une thématique
d'actualité euh donc commençons si vous
le voulez bien par un peu de de contexte
quelques considérations politiques et
économique qui informe et le l'approche
britannique donc tout
d'abord le défi démocratique est déjà
été un petit peu évoqué mais je vais je
je souhaiterai approfondir un peu en
2050 plus d'un quart de la population
active mondiale à vivra en Afrique 1/5e
de la population mondiale totale donc 2
milliards de la population mondiale
totale vivra en Afrique il y a un vrai
potentiel en terme de croissance
économique 11 pays sur le continent
africain connaîtront cette année une
croissance de plus de 5,5 % mais le
continent fait face à ce que mousafaki
le président de la Commission de l'Union
africaine a décrit comme des problèmes
bien connus c'est-à-dire des récents
changements non démocratiques de
gouvernement qui sont pour nous un grand
sujet de de préoccupation un accès au
financement privé pour le dévelop vement
qui est en quantité insuffisante et des
taux
raisonnables d'intérêt ce qui qui reste
un grand problème sur le plan économique
et ensuite comme mes collègues l'ont
évoqué un peu aussi les effets conjugués
du covid de l'invasion de l'Ukraine du
changement climatique et des
institutions faibles ont aggravé la
situation économique sur le continent
africain ont aggravé le développement la
situation sécuritaire également des de
la plupart des pays africains et c'est
en Afrique subsaharienne que les
Objectifs du millénaire pour le
développement sont les plus éloignés de
la réalité l'instabilité augmente en
particulier dans un arc qui va du Sahel
à l'ouest et du Nigéria jusqu'au Soudan
et à la Corne de l'Afrique à l'est et le
récent coup d'État au Niger et le 9e
coup d'État dans la région depuis
2019 donc pour nous pour le Royaume-Uni
si rien n fait l'instabilité région et
la fragilité des états risque d'aggraver
les crises humanitaires d'exacerber la
migration irrégulière surtout de
compromettre le développement et de
créer un espace pour le terrorisme et
pour l'activité d'État hostile j'y
reviendrai ces risques ont un impact
direct sur la sécurité et la prospérité
du Royaume-Uni de la France et de
l'Europe il faut aussi tenir en compte
le rôle géopolitique de l'Afrique qui
est important pour nous l'Afrique contte
54 voies à l'ONU c'est le plus grand
bloc régional aux Nations unies pour
nous dans le Commonwealth 21 des 54 pays
du Commonwealth sont
africain pour parler un petit peu de de
l'histoire que nous avons dans la région
parce que c'est c'est un une perspective
que nous partageons avec la France le
Royaume-Uni la France ont tous les deux
une longue histoire des intérêts des
partenariats avec de nombreux pays
africains nous restons deux des plus
grands
investisseurs du continent en terme de
stock de capital
nous entretenons des liens diplomatiques
culturels de développement de de
sécurité important avec les peuples et
les États d'Afrique et nous continuons
contribuons pardon tous deux de manière
significative aux efforts de maintien de
paix sur le continent que ce soit par le
soutien l'ONU ou le soutien aux missions
africaines mais l'augmentation de la
capacité économique et de l'intérêt
actif pour l'Afrique d'un certain nombre
de pays en particulier la Chine mais
aussi l'Inde certains états du moy
Orient surtout dans le golf et dans une
certaine mesure aussi la Russie signifie
que les dirigeants africains ont le
sentiment de disposer d'un choix de
partenaire potentiel plus large que dans
le
passé dans cet environnement je voudrais
maintenant vous exposer l'approche du
Royaume-Uni en Afrique et nos
objectifs sur ce continent comme comme
l'ont fait mes collègues allemands et et
italien avant moi donc le le cadre
global pour la politique étrangère et
sécuritaire international britannique
est un document qui s'appelle the
integrated review la revue intégrée qui
était publiée en 2021 et qui a été mise
à jour l'année dernière en 2023 euh et
c'est un peu l'équivalent de votre revue
National stratégique ce document
présente l'approche globale du
gouvernement britannique y compris des
éléments sur nos nos relations avec le
continent africain nous nous proposons à
l'Afrique c'est le fondement de notre
approche des partenariats constants
fondés sur des principes travaillant
avec nos aliés et nos partenaires sur
des questions qui sont importantes pour
nos partenaires africains AF afin
d'assurer la stabilité une croissance
durable et la réduction de la
pauvreté nous croyons en des part
partenariats distinctifs modernes fondés
sur le respect le choix le bénéfice
mutuel les intérêts communs et nous
insistons que nous sommes nous sommes à
l'écoute des besoins des pays africains
et c'est c'est ainsi que nous nous
pensons pouvoir construire des
partenariat durable avec les pays et les
institutions d'Afrique qui conduiront à
un continent plus libre plus sûr plus
prospère plus vert et en meilleure santé
si je voulais résumer je dirai que les
les objectifs du Royaume-Uni en Afrique
sont promouvoir la démocratie et une
bonne gouvernance ensuite renforcer nos
partenariats sécuritaires et de
défense tisser des liens économiques
pour une croissance durable rendre la
planète plus propre et plus verte
ensuite aider les femmes et les jeunes
filles à s'émanciper et à investir dans
le développement
humain soutenir une réponse humanitaire
efficace approfondir notre coopération
scientifique technologique et pour
l'innovation et ensuite agir contre les
flux migratoires irrégulier et tout cela
et j'insiste là-dessus à la base d'un
partenariat long terme et fiable où nous
appuyons les africains et leurs
institutions si vous le permettez je
vais maintenant aborder notre
partenariat avec la France et euh nos
autres nos autres partenaires
internationaux pour progresser notre
coopération tout d'abord basé à sur
notre notre dialogue avec les les
dirigeants africains nous savons nous
entendons qu's veulent des partenariats
authentiques fondés sur le respect
mutuel et qui leur permettent de relever
eux-mêmes les défis et de libérer le
potentiel de croissance de leur pays et
c'est une opportunité lors du sommet
franco-britannique de mars dernier un
moment important pour notre relation
bilatérale le Royaume-Uni et la France
se sont engagés à accroître notre
coopération bilatérale sur les questions
africaines euh ça cela formalise des
liens qui existaient déjà mais ça
démontre également notre intention de de
renforcer notre coopération sur sur
l'Afrique ensuite et mon collègue
italien a soulevé ce point nous voulons
aussi continuer à travailler dans les
enceintes multilatérales notamment le G7
le G20 et en tant que membre permanent
du Conseil de sécurité euh qui afin
d'atteindre nos objectifs euh et cela
comprend une réforme significative du
système multilatéral afin de mieux
refléter les intérêts des pays africains
la voix des pays africains doivent ou
les voix pardon doivent être entendues
dans les autres hautes sphères du monde
et nous sommes donc favorables à une
grande représentation africaine dans les
institutions multilatérales y compris
dans le Conseil de sécurité des Nations
unies nous insitons aussi sur la
nécessité de réformer le système
financier
international le sommet du G7 sous la
sous-présidence italienne cette année
aussi permettra de mettre l'accent sur
l'Afrique et nous appuyerons tout à fait
cela euh nous pourrions mieux dans ce
cadre articul une offre internationale
sur les infrastructures sur les
investissements mondiaux aider la
résolution de problèmes tels que la
fragilité des États africains les
conflits le changement climatique tous
qui sont tous des facteurs de migration
à l'intérieur de l'Afrique et en
provenance de l'Afrique vers l'Europe
nous soutenons depuis longtemps une
participation africaine au sein du G20
et lors du sommet du G20 à nudali nous
avvez nous avons progressé dans ce sens
avec le renforcement de la voix de
l'Afrique en en accueillant l'Union
africaine comme nouvant m permanent du
G20 un autre élément important pour nous
dans le cadre de notre action
multilatérale est le partenariat du P3
c'est le Royaume-Uni la France les
États-Unis qui est très important dans
le cadre africain en particulier pour
mettre en œuvre les politiques de l'ONU
euh et nous Contin continuerons à à à
appuyer le le rôle du P3 sur le
continent
ensuite je je souhaitais aborder
brièvement euh en dernier lieu quelques
quelques points sur notre approche sur
le le soutien à la démocratie en Afrique
puisque c'est vraiment une thématique
d'actualité dans le cadre des coups dans
le Sahel que nous avons à nous avons
observé et vécu la promotion de la
démocratie est une pierre angulaire pour
nous dans notre approche nous sommes
ouvert au fait que nous utilisation nous
utilisons notre relation de défense avec
l'Afrique pour influencer la trajectoire
politique euh des gouvernements non
démocratiques par exemple à la suite du
coup d'état survenu en au Niger l'année
dernière nous avons suspendu tout
soutien bilatéral en matière de défense
en coordination avec nos nos alliés
français et américains et nous
maintenons une position similaire au
Burkina Faso et au Mali nous pensons que
des institutions démocratiqu fortes des
gouvernements responsables qui défendent
les droits universels et l'état de droit
sont des éléments clés pour des états
sûr et prospère et nous nous travaillons
donc à la promotion de ces principes par
le biais de nos ambassades en Afrique
par euh les organisations multilatérales
que j'ai cité euh et par nos soutiens
également aux organismes régionaux la
CDAO que vous avez déjà mentionné euh en
éthune et pour être très concret le
soutien du Royaume-Uni eu sur les
affaires politiques de paix et de
sécurité à l'Union africaine c'est élevé
à 26 millions de livres eu sterling euh
en 2022 2023 couvrant par exemple les
indignnités versées à la miss africaine
de transition en Somalie et les travaux
de l'Union africaine sur les transitions
politiques et les changements
antionstitutionnels de gouvernement donc
nous nous donc nous faisons de cette
élément de promotion de démocratie un
élément vraiment concret de notre
approche pour citer juste deux ou trois
petits exemples nous soutenons aussi par
exemple la Formation Judiciaire autour
des élections au Kenya nous nous l'avons
fait nous nous soutenons la gestion de
finances publiques au Mozambique nous
soutenons à la société civile et la la
prestation de service au
Nigéria et nous soutenons également le
programme de l'Union africaine sur les
conflits et la gouvernance avec un un
montant de 7 millions de livres sur des
axes sur la protection des femmes la
paix et la sécurité l'observation
électorale et l'alerte précoce en cas de
de
conflit finalement un un mot bref sur le
le Commonwealth qui est une institution
importante et stratégique pour le
Royaume-Uni une instiation basée sur des
valeurs partager une institution
historique qui reste euh tout à fait
courante euh et qui traite bien sûr
entre autres des questions climatiques
économiques et l'avancée de de nos
valeurs sur le continent africain c'est
aussi une organisation importante pour
la famille royale et vous avez mentionné
vous avez été très gentil de mentionner
le l'accueil euh par le roi Charles de
Cyril ramafossa à au Royaume-Uni à
l'année dernière h nous avons aussi euh
eu le plaisir de de d'accueillir le le
roi Charles ici en France et la visite
d'État qu'il a fait après la France
était au Kenya donc pour pour enenforcer
un peu ces
liens du Commonwealth également voilà je
je pense que j'ai j'ai bien fait le le
point sur notre approche merci beaucoup
messieurs mesdames je vous remercie pour
vos votre écoute et ravi de de répondre
aux questions merci beaucoup messieurs
pour ces présentations exhaustives et
extrêmement précis nous en venons
maintenant aux orateurs des groupes en
commençant par le groupe Renaissance
benoî Borda pour 2 minutes messieurs les
ministres Messieurs les Présidents chers
collègues au nom du groupe Renaissance
je vous remercie pour vos propos
liminires qui nous permettent d'affiner
l'ampleur des enjeux cela a été dit
l'Afrique est incontournable dans 25 ans
c'est 1 milliard d'habitants en plus
avec un/ers de la population qui aura
moins de 35 ans depuis le discours de
wadouu en 2017 la France s'engage dans
un partenariat renouvelé avec les pays
africains visant à bâtir un nouveau
modèle de
partenariat tout en renforçant les liens
avec les sociétés civiles et les
secteurs privés cette refonte a
également été au cœur du nouveau sommet
afrique-fance en octobre 2021 à
Montpellier réaffirmant notre volonté de
collaborer sur un pied d'égalité dans un
esprit de réciprocité et de
responsabilité
mutuelle nous faisons face à un contexte
en constante évolution la montée des
groupes terroristes dans la région
sahelocarienne et leur expansion
territoriale d'autant que les États-Unis
réorientent leur stratégie vers la zone
indopacifique laissant ainsi l'Europe
face à des nouveaux enjeux de sécurité à
proximité
immédiate vous l'avez dit notre approche
doit être européenne dans ce casadre
j'aimerais adresser une question au
docteur Martin Cheffer l'Europe la
France l'Allemagne se sont longtemps
cantonnés à des liens historiques et
géographique qu'on imaginait pouvoir
nous conférer des avantages comparatifs
immuables par rapport au sud global
force de constater que beaucoup de pays
africains ont Issé des liens étroits
avec la Chine le golf la Turquie et dans
le domaine de la coopération militaire
avec la Russie compte tenu de l'objectif
de l'Allemagne de mener une politique de
développement mondial avec l'Afrique en
tant que partenaire clé et de
l'importance croissante de l'Afrique
dans les affaires mondiales comment
l'approche de l'Allemagne axée sur le
respect mutuel la réciprocité et la
promotion des droits humains peut-elle
remodeler les dynamiques actuelles et
peut-être atténuer l'influence de la
Chine et de la Russie sur le continent
je vous remercie merci beaucoup la
parole est à Laurent jacobelli pour le
groupe rassemblement national et pour 2
minutes merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
mur messieurs et au nom du groupe
rassemblement national j'aimerais vous
remercier de vous être exprimé en
français c'est une marque de respect et
d'honneur pour la représentation
nationale c'était un français en plus
parfait je tiens à vous le dire et c'est
une attention qui je crois a été a été
REM remarqué j'aimerais tout d'abord
faire une remarque liminaire vous avez
beaucoup d'entre vous évoqué des
relations bilatérales voire trilatérales
notamment sur le le continent africain
et peut-être aurions-nous pu avoir
plusieurs réunions plusieurs commissions
avec chacun d'entre vous pour avoir des
questions plus particulières tant nos
coopérations varient en fonction des
zones et même dans leur nature en
Afrique aujourd'hui face au péril
islamiste face au risques majeurs
migratoire face à la lutte d'influence
que nous mène la Russie et la Chine sur
le continent africain nos nations c'est
une évidence ont tout intérêt à
travailler ensemble en Afrique alors
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant des
jeintes militaires ont contraint la
France à se retirer des pays où elle
était traditionnellement je citerai
évidemment le Burkina Faso le Mali et
plus récemment encore le Niger dans le
sillage de ce retrait forcé parfois nos
ambassad et nos personnels diplomatiques
ont été la cible d'attaque les nouveaux
régimes en place des régimes qui ne sont
pas démocratiques nous sont profondément
hostile et vous le savez il ne s'en
cache pas d'ailleurs il s'agit là d'une
rupture stratégique majeure pour la
France bien évidemment mais j'imagine
aussi pour tous ses partenaires sur le
continent africain comment messieurs
aendez-vous ce changement qu quelle
stratégie quz vous mettre en place pour
y répondre quel impact sur la poursuite
des opérations antiterroristes que vous
menez au côté de la France dans certains
pays en allant plus loin cette nouvelle
donne impactera-t-elle votre présence
dans les pays africains concernés et je
tiens à le dire ces éléments sont
importants et votre présence aujourd'hui
est très importante pour éclairer ces
pointant parfois le doute peut nous
habiter quand on lit par exemple
certains article dans la presse qui nous
explique que un de nos partenaires
l'Allemagne aurait hésité à nous livrer
des poches de sang à niamet pour ne pas
offenser laaginte en place tous ces
éléments sont extrêmement importants
pour maintenir des des relations
sereines prospère et surtout efficace
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup la parole
est à Aurélien saintoule pour le groupe
de la France
insoumise merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci messieurs les ministres
de vos propos de vos présen euh vous
avez euh manifester une grande
convergence de vue entre vous et avec la
France puisque nos principes concordent
en réalité et vous avez largement brossé
le le panorama des grands défis qui sont
devant nous et qui sont devant
évidemment tous les peuples africains la
question du développement la question de
la transition écologique et de
euh de de la démocratie évidemment moi
j'ai quelques questions précises que je
souhaiterais poser à à chacun d'entre
vous la première peut-être euh à
Monsieur à Monsieur Cacho
euh la France et l'Italie se sont opposé
ces notoir sur la la question du dossier
libyen j'aimerais aujourd'hui savoir si
euh nous êtes nous sommes en mesure de
converger euh la France a apporté un
soutien discret mais néanmoins avéré au
général aftar qu'en est-il aujourd'hui
notre capacité à à agir de concert euh
sur sur ce dossier une question à à
Monsieur
Chefa concernant la participation de de
l'Allemagne à le UTM et en et aussi à la
minusma nous avons eu vent du fait
notamment par exemple que l'Allemagne
avait utilisé ou en tout cas avait
déployé des moyens de renseignement mais
que n'avait pas forcément toujours été
en mesure de transmettre ces
renseignements cet imagerie plutôt à la
minusma que à ses partenaires notamment
États-Unis j'aimerais savoir si vous
pouvez nous en don dire un peu plus sur
ce sujet puis une question à Monsieur
saoul concernant euh le Common Wells et
la façon dont peut-être la candidature
de certains grands africains au nouveau
bricks peut avoir un un impact sur votre
stratégie et sur votre vision du du
continent je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est à
Jean-Louis tiierot pour le groupe des
Républicains pour 2 minutes merci
monsieur le Président merci messieurs de
de ces exposés globales une question
générale et puis après de petites
question à à certains d'entre vous
question générale la France a été
victime d'attaque informationnelle
extrêmement importante en Afrique en
particulier
au Sahel on a pu voir à la fois que ça
résultait d'un état d'esprit local et
aussi
que un certain nombre de nos
compétiteurs stratégiques la Russie
notamment pour ne pas les citer avait
joué un rôle important dans ses attaque
informationnelle j'aurais souhaité
savoir dans chacun de de vos pays
respectifs et de vos ressentis
respectifs est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'être victime d'attaque
informationnell et quelle est la
stratégie que vous avez mis en œuvre
pour lutter contre ces ces menaces qui
sont un des composants d'une guerre
hybride plus général deux questions qui
s'adressent à l'un d'entre vous en
particulier l'une à Martin schffer je
crois que nous avons eu une visite du
ministre de la Défense allemand monsieur
Pistorius en décembre à niamet au moment
où nous étions en train de nous retirer
donc j'aurais souhaité savoir quelle
avait été le l'objet de cette visite et
ce qu'il en était ressorti enfin une
question à Monsieur euh cachio vous avez
évoqué le plan mati vous avez dans votre
doctrine de défense le concept très
important de Méditerranée élargie donc
j'aurais souhaité savoir comment le plan
Marti s'articule avec le concept de
Méditerranée élargie je vous remercie
merci beaucoup la parole est à Sabine
tiller pour le groupe démocrate merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président tout
d'abord au nom du groupe modem merci
pour vos interventions messieurs et
toutes mes excuses pour mon arrivée
tardive et je pose cette question aussi
au nom de mon collègue Christophe
Blanchet alors vous avez évoqué qu'il
faut accompagner la transformation
sociale pour assurer la stabilité et la
paix alors si il apparaît quand même
qu'un bon nombre des pays africains
subissent un fléo au plus haut niveau de
l'État c'est la corruption que ce soit
dans les pays démocratique ou non
chchons cette contrainte pour atteindre
vos objectifs doit-on faire avec à
défaut de valoriser notre idéal de la
démocratie à l'occidental parce que
souvent on a aussi une attitude
l'Afrique a les problèmes nous avons les
solutions euh est-ce que il faut pas un
changement parfois aussi de logiciel
dans notre approche de l'Afrique parce
que je crois que là aussi même tout on é
évidemment être attaché à l'État de
droit et à la démocratie l'histoire nous
a montré que ça peut venir que de
l'intérieur des pays et pas être
euh
euh voilà
ah
merci merci beaucoup la parole est à
Anna pic pour le groupe socialiste
apparenté merci euh Messieurs les
Présidents messieurs cela ne nous aura
pas échappé une page historique des
relations de la France à l'Afrique s'est
définitivement tourné au cours des
derniers mois tant du point de vue
militaire qu'économique ou politique
transformé par une démographie dynamique
faisant ce continent l'un des plus
jeunes mais aussi sous l'effet de la
numérisation et de l'accès au savoir et
à la culture les sociétés africaines se
sont transformées et surtout mondialisé
cette nouvelle donne associée à plus de
10 ans de présence militaire française
tantôt sitaire tantôt chaotique nous
oblige à penser la reconfiguration de
nos relations raison pour laquelle nous
sommes réunis aujourd'hui alors que
notre affaiblissement s'acenté nombre
d'États dont certains sont des alliés
ont renforcé leurs leur influence à
titre d'exemple la France perdu depuis
2017 son statut de premier fournisseur
européen du marché africain dépassé par
l'Allemagne il va de même s'agissant
départs de marché cette politique est
pour différentes raisons assumé par ces
états du fait de la reconfiguration des
relations international longtemps ignoré
par des entreprises allemandes
focalisées sur l'Asie ou encore l'Europe
de l'Est l'Allemagne a fait désormais de
son du continent africain un marché à
conquérir et une priorité comme vous
nous l'avez dit euh monsieur le ministre
affaibli pendant par le brexit le
Royaume-Uni souhaite affirmer sa
position en tant qu'investisseur là
aussi vous avez précisé ces éléments de
premier plan en Afrique et accueillera
en avril prochain un sommet sur
l'investissement entre le Royaume-Uni et
l'Afrique l'Italie dans un objectif
migratoire mais aussi d'investissement
économique souhaite relancer ses
rapports avec le continent en se
focalisant sur la stratégique Corne de
l'Afrique et vous nous avez là aussi
décrit le tous les axes que vous
souhaitez développer force est de
constater donc que cette voie vers le
renforcement s'effectue dans une forme
de compétition entre pays européens
alors que l'efficacité de notre aide au
développement du continent africain
réside sans doute dans un effort
européen collectif alors deux questions
d'abord puisque nous sommes réunis ici
pour avoir un un travail autour de la
reconfiguration de nos relations vous en
tant que partenaire de la France quel
regard avez-vous sur le travail que nous
avons initié à l'Assemblée nationale et
et que nous tentons de mener pour
clarifier nos positions et j'ai bien
entendu la volonté des uns et des autres
d'une plus grande rération européenne
des actions de notre de de nos actions
quelles articulations entre relations
bilatérales et coopération entre
organisations régionales et continental
pouvons-nous merci beaucoup la parole
est à Christophe Plard pour le groupe
horizon merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les présidents de commission
Messieurs les Ambassadeurs mes chers
collègues tout d'abord je rejoins les
les les remerciements collectifs pour
vos interventions respectives précises
et détaillées l'histoire complexe de la
présence du continent européen en
Afrique est vu comme une opportunité
pour nos compétiteurs la répentance de
l'Europe vis-à-vis de la colonisation
suivie d'un excès de précaution dans nos
partenariats en Afrique ont laissé le
champ libre à des pays dont la stratégie
politique de de domination est assumée
ainsi nos pays respectifs ne font pas
face seulement à une compéation une
compétition économique et commerciale
mais aussi à une contestation
diplomatique et militaire avec de
l'autre côté du rideau notamment la
Russie et la Chine la présence
financière et militaire via les
mercenaires dans ces deux pays d'Afrique
est plus actuelle que jamais leur
objectif est simple mettre en place une
colonisation économique du continent en
dénonçant par le biais de la de la
propagande et de la désinformation la
responsabilité de nos pays en raison
d'événements survenus il y a maintenant
plus d'un siècle ce n'est pas seulement
la France qui est visée dans ses œuvres
mais toute l' Europe entière et qui est
désigné comme l'ennemi de l'Afrique par
ses régimes autoritaires je vais
rejoindre la question de de mon collègue
Jean-Louis tiierot tout à l'heure et je
voulais savoir donc au-delà de la
réaffirmation de notre volonté de
maintenir des relations diplomatiques et
commerciales fortes avec l'Afrique bien
entendu si vos gouvernements respectifs
ont entrepris des mesures pour contrer
ces opérations de propagande et de
déstabilisation et si oui par quel moyen
et si un partenariat entre nos pays est
envisageable sur ce spectre de la
désinformation et de la propagande je
vous remercie merci beaucoup messieurs
vous avez la parole pour répondre à
toutes ces questions peut-être en
reprenant l'ordre initial si cela vous
vous va
ainsi monsieurs mesdames les député
merci de de ces ces questions
euh assez large et et je vais essayer de
mon meieux
de donner des réponses concrètes alors
je crois que c'est une belle et bonne
occasion euh pour parler en public
monsieur les députés sur les rumeurs qui
courent et qu'on trouve effectivement
aussi dans les médias français sur un
présumé manque manque de coopération
manque de de volonté de coopérer avec la
France de la part de l'Allemagne de son
contingent militaire à propos des fameux
Pr de sang je vous dis très clairement
monsieurs les députés que ces rumeurs
sont
fausses et que les militaires français
de très haut niveau ont reconnu dans les
contacts bilatéraux que ne que ce
n'était pas ainsi et que ce que a fait
l'armée
allemande en soutien pour le retrait et
la présence de l'armée française au
Niger a été comme il faut et que le fait
que l'ÉE allemande a tenu à continuer à
parler avec le régime de facto de Niger
de Niger pour faire en sorte qu'il y a
encore des allers-retours en avion entre
nous et l'Union européenne et le Niger a
été un facteur clé aussi en soutien pour
la France pour soutenir au retrait donc
je suis très heureux que vous ayez posé
cette question pour une fois pour toutes
vous confirmer que ce n'était pas ainsi
et cette vision est compartie par par
par les autorités compétentes compétente
de la France il
est et là je reviens monsieur le député
Tero à votre question sur la présence du
ministre pistorios à Niamé je suis tenta
de vous donner une une
citation une citation d'un d'un grand
homme britannique parce que il me manque
la situation du général de Gaulle
là-dessus je crois que Churchill a dit
une fois if two people agree on si deux
personnes sont d'accord sur sur tout et
bien one of themneary un de est
rédondant et que je je cite le Premier
ministre Churchill dans ce contexte pour
ne pas dire que qu' qu'on a des des des
points de vue divergent sur la situation
illégale au Niger mais on a des des des
points de vue je crois qu'un petit peu
différent sur l'approche pour faire en
sorte que nos intérêts sont sont
sauvegardés et que et que le le ministre
Pistorius a pris la décision de se
rendre à Niamé dans la
poursuite de de sa présence au sommet de
de la
CDAO et pour apporter des des des des
propositions de médiation pour faire en
sorte que la Carelle entre le CDAO et le
Niger puisse être résolu et en plus il
est vrai que nous avons eu affaire à un
retrait compliqué et dangereux dans la
même mesure
que que la France et que le ministre a
tenu nécessaire de parler au plus haut
niveau avec le régime de facto pour
faire en sorte que ce retrait des
troupes allemandes et peut-être aussi
d'autres troupes se fassent d'une
manière digne et sans porter trop de
risque à nos officiers et soldats les
résultats ont été pour ainsi dire pas
complète et que et et que au moins
au moins le retrait des troupes
allemands a a été fait d'une manière
d'une manière organisée et qu'on n pas
eu à se plaindre des des des victimes ou
des des des attaques ou des problèmes
des problèmes qui qui qui ont pu
Ourir sonans ces pour palis du ministre
de de défense alors sur les les autres
questions permettez-moi de vous dire sur
la question de la
générale à l'égard de l'Afrique je crois
que surtout avec cette nécessité pour la
France de
réconfigurer assez profondément sa
politique à l'égard de l'Afrique et
surtout à l'égard de l'Afrique
francophone je crois que vraiment et je
l'ai dit dans mes propos préliminaires
je crois que c'est vraiment une chance
pour nous tous de se mettre d'accord et
que et que de définir des objectifs
communs en tant qu'Européens et de
lesett mettre en œuvre avec avec toutes
nos forces et avec nos forces qui sont
différents entre les uns et les autres
madame la députée vous avez énoncé une
approche commerciale agressive de
l'Allemagne et bien je je je tiens à
vous rappeler que dans les échange
commerciant de l'Allemagne avec le monde
entier je crois que
l'Afrique ne constitue même pas 1
% et que j'ai j'ai l'expérience de mon
poste d'ambassadeur d'Allemagne en
Afrique du Sud 50 % de ces de ces
échanges commerciaux avec l'Afrique se
font pour des raisons historiques avec
l'Afrique du Sud nous pensons
effectivement que les échanges
commerciaux sont un facteur positif pour
le développement de tout le monde pas
seulement pour nous mais aussi pour nos
partenaires comm commerciaux et si
effectivement l'Allemagne et tous les
autres part partenaires de l'Afrique
arrivent à augmenter les échanges
commerciau avec l'Afrique je crois en
premier lieu c'est une une bonne chose
qui sera qui sera bien pour pour pour
tout le monde alors sur les les
problèmes de de d'échange des
renseignement au Mali dans le cadre de
minusma etutm Monsieur le député je peux
je suis pas vraiment en mesure de de
parler ouvertement là-dessus parce qu'il
s'agit quand même des des questions
assez opératives et comme nous parlons
ici euh en en espace public je crois que
il fautrait trouver un autre forum pour
pour bien euh pour bien en en parler et
je m'excuse de cette réponse peut-être
peu satisfaisante en ce qui concerne les
deux questions sur les attaques
informationnelles sur la propagande je
crois que il est vrai que dans certains
pays d'Afrique la France est un cible
particulièrement clairire pour ceux qui
veulent que que qui ont des autres
objectifs que nous pour un développement
durable de de de de l'Afrique je peux
vous assurer monsieur les députés
mesdames les députés contre la France
l'Allemagne il y a déjà euh ici et
aujourd'hui des coopérations euh pour
l'analyse des risques et des dangers des
attaques informationnelles et pour contr
contrarier la la propagande et les fake
news et que bien sûr il y a beaucoup
d'espace pour encore améliorer
intensifier ces ces C cette cette cette
forme de coopération pour contrarier ce
flot dont je partage tout à fait vos
sentiments euh de d'être enragé euh là
de ce finalement euh oui h madame la
députée vous avez parlé de la corruption
en Afrique j'aimerais bien vous partager
avec vous quelques expériences à propos
de mon mon séjour en Afrique du Sud
peut-être parce que c'était World News
en quelque sorte vous êtes au courant un
petit peu de l'affaire il y avait un
grand réseau de corruption en Afrique du
Sud dans le cadre même du du du du
président du du pays du président Zuma
on estime que 5 à 6 % du PIB du PIB ont
été détournés pendant une durée de de de
de 10 ans dans le cadre de cette de
cette cette affaire et je peux vous dire
que la manière dont ça a été découvert
la manière dont ça a été traité eu a été
admirable et respectable dans le sens
que c'était la société civile c'était
les médias libres de du du pays même de
l'Afrique du Sud qui ont découvert tout
ce que se passait et qui ont poussé le
gouvernement et les autorités
judiciaires à faire en sorte que les les
les les criminels sontapéhandés et que
ce flot de la corruption so soit Comat
combattu comme comme il faut il est il
est bien clair que la corruption existe
en Afrique comme elle existe dans tous
les autres continents et je crois que il
correspond à nos valeurs à nous tous
ensemble de de de de de combattir ce
flot et je crois que ça passe simplement
à travers des renforcements des
institutions de nos de nos partenaires
ça a été l'approche européen en Afrique
du Sud et ça doit être l'approche dans
d'autres pays d'Afrique aussi pour faire
en sorte que la corruption ne soit pas
un facteur qui contrariait la la
croissance économique et le bien-être
des des
sociétés alors je m'arrête ici monsieur
le Président très bien merci beaucoup
monsieur
Cassio merci monsieur le Président merci
mesames les députés messieurs les
députés pour toutes les questions donc
euh un en commençant par la question
générale disons de de de l'attitude des
pays européens la question de la
compétition la collaboration je crois
que je l' dit mes collègues aussi pour
nous il n'y a pas de solutions à
l'échelle nationale pour ce qui conc
l'Afrique toutes les grandes questions
qui qui qui qui qui nous se présentent
et ça c'est ça peut pas étonner en
connaissant l'histoire de l'Italie
disons de son engagement dans la
construction européenne dès les débuts
dans les institutions internationales
donc il pe il peut avoir il y a de la
compétition entre les entreprises d'un
pays ou de l'autre ça c'est normal nous
sommes un pays exporteur nous avons des
entreprises qui sont intéressées aux
investissement en Afrique mais là aussi
je crois que notre échange commerci
commercial avec l'Afrique c'est plus ou
moins l'amour moitié de ce qu'on a avec
la France et et pour ce qui concerne la
balance commerciale avec l'Afrique c'est
très déficitaire la balance de l'Italie
au contraire de la France donc voilà
c'est c'est je on ne voit vraiment ça
pas du tout en terme des compétition on
est absolument convaincu que il nous
faut une action des de l'Union
européenne vers les les continents
africain on s'est battu à Bruxelles pour
avoir des ressources sur l'instrument de
politique étrangère de de de l'Union
européenne et sur la facilité pour la
paix qui soit réservé à l'Afrique parce
que c'est une priorité que que nous
partageons et et les fait d'avoir
coopéré dans les passés par exemple par
la France je je rappelis l'exemple de
takuba c'est un exemple qui qui me
touche personnellement parce que j'ai
passé quelques années à l'OTAN à
Bruxelles à la représentation permanente
d'Italie à l'OTAN je me rappelle bien
j'étais là en 2013 quand la France à
lancé cal on nous avait demandé de
participer à à l'opération Serval avec
deux avions de trans sport et à l'époque
on avait même pas réussi à d'avoir une
majorité au Parlement pour même si le
gouvernement auraient bien voulu le
faire pour pour donner une contribution
qui était plus un geste politique qu'une
véritable contribution opérationnelle
tandis que ce qu'on avait mis à
disposition de Touba c'était de des
moyens opérationnels d'un certains
niveau c'est-à-dire de de de de des
hélicoptèes
mdevac des assz de de de de niveau
disons pas donc non c'est c'est pour
nous la la coopération dans les cas de
l'Union européenne dans les cas des G7
avec des partenaires comme le
Royaume-Uni du G20 dans les cas des
nations- Unies c'est essentiel on y
arriverait jamais jamais seul cela dit
eu sur quoi faire face à C que que qui a
été défini une rupture stratégique
majeure dans les pays du CEL et cetera
on est d'accord
que qu'il y a eu qui qu'il y a un
problème sur comment s'y prendre en fait
il y a quelques nuances disons entre
nous nous sommes convaincus là je disais
aussi que la pire erreur ça serait de
laisser en vide de laisser à d'autres un
espace à remplir en disons ok on coupe
tout toute coopération et et voilà on
s'en va ça laisse un espace nos
compétiteur pour mettre en place des
solutions qui ne sont évidemment
évidemment pas les les bons pour les
pays de la région et qui représente un
perspective en danger pour notre
sécurité notre stabilité nos intérêts
donc voilà on sait bien que on peut pas
négliger ce qui est arrivé évidemment on
continue pas de coopérer avec des
régimes qui sont là suite un coup d'état
qu' rien n'était et et ça on l'a fait on
a établi une ligne commune à Bruxelles
envers les les pays du Sahel on la de
les pays où où il y a eu des coups
d'État on la on la suit mais il faut
être prêt à recéommencer c'est réengager
éviter de de laisser les les les champs
à à d'autres
euh sur la voilà sur la même ligne sur
la question de la de la corruption là là
aussi évidemment je suis d'accord avec
mon collègue allemand il y a de la
corruption en Afrique comme il y a dans
dans d'autres pays du monde même dans
nos pays il y a de la corruption pour
nous la lutte à la tion très important c
là aussi une question qu'on va traiter
dans le cadre du G7 comme on avait fait
aussi pendant notre dernière présidence
même du point de vue de comment mesurer
la corruption qui est une question très
importante et pas encore disons tranché
parce que c'est c'est un problème là
aussi mais encore il faut lutter contre
la corruption il faut faire les
possibles on les fait avec les
programmes d'assistance aux autorités
locales mais on on on peut pas dire ok
il y a la corruption on on termine de
coopérer avec ces pays non il faut
s'engager pour continuer de coopérer en
essayant de faire le poss possible pour
réduire la corruption pour mettre ces
pays en condition de se battre d'une
manière efficace contre la coruption et
soutenir exactement la société civile en
même temps qui est la mieux placée
disons pour avoir une perception plus
précise de la corruption dans un pays et
pour et pour amener des des des des tion
euh sur la question de la propagande oui
c'est un problème commun même si la
France évidemment était les pays les
plus exposés dans les pays dans la
région du Sahel pas seulement pour des
raison historique pour sa présence en
Afrique donc on a bien vu que que que la
France était la la première victime de
la desinformation de la propagande
d'autres puissances parfois alimenté par
d'autres puissances parfois aussi par
des forces locales mais pour vous
raconter un épisode l'Italie n'a pas été
épargnée par ça je me rappelle avoir lu
sur plusieurs journaux français la euh
la nouvelle que l'attaché militaire
l'attaché de défense italienne à Niamé
avait été décoré par la junte militaire
pas du tout il avait reçu une décoration
du président bazum pas de de de
nouvelles autorité mais ça c'est c'est
ce qui est passé sur sur le Gun donc il
faut faire attention il faut réagir et
euh c'est pas par hasard qu'une des
questions que nous allons soulever et
traité avec priorité dans les G7 pendant
notre présidence G7 c'est la question de
l'intelligence artificielle et comment
aussi l'intelligence artificielle peut
être utilisée pour la propagande et pour
contrer la
propagande négative
euh une question
sur les contestations encore encore dans
le cas de la propagande des activités de
nos compétiteurs stratégiques je trouve
là aussi il faut faire attention à ne
pas trop se contentrer se concentrer sur
les autres
c'est-à-dire ce n'est pas forcément une
bonne idée d'aller dire vous ne devez
pas faire des choses avec la Chine la
Russie nous devons convaincre les pays
de l'Afrique que nous avons une solution
meilleure après il n'y a notre problème
ce n'est pas de dire ne faites pas ça
avec la Chine c'est c'est de dire faites
ça avec nous c'est et et et c'est une
nuance peut-être de perspective mais là
aussi pas pas négligeable je dire euh
sur la question merci pour la question
relation entre les les plans matille et
l'idée de la Méditerranée élargie en
fait c'est les deux font partie de la
même vision parce qu'il y a les mêmes
défis si si on veut des filles qui ont
un côté sécuritaire un côté lié au
développement économique
sociale et où on peut pas traiter l'un s
l'autre c'est veut dire on peut pas
s'attacher seulement la dimension
sécuritaire en négligence qui est le
développement économique la croissance
sociale tout là et on peut on peut pas
faire l'invers non plus
donc c'est pourquoi nous participons par
exemple à des missions militaires en
Afrique mais aussi à des missions
militaires dans la Méditerranée on vient
de lancer avec la France l'Allemagne la
mission dans le dans le dans mer Rouge
donc voilà c'est c'est part d'un même du
même approche et là aussi on est
convaincu que c'est c'est une approche
en Réant à la question de des
initiatives nationales pour nous les
plan matille c'est et et les sommets
Itali Afrique les premier sommet Itali
Afrique qu' fait maintenant c'est oui
c'est une initiative nationale mais qui
a le le but de de lancer un processus
qui puisse être développ à niveau
européen comme quand je sais pas la la
France organise un sommet avec l'Afrique
on on pense pas que c'est c'est
initiative nationale qui va s'arrêter là
parce qu'évidemment la France aussi a
tout l'intérêt à développer des
coopérations dans d'autres cadre et je
suis content de la présence aussi de
notre collègue britannique pour dire
qu'il n'y a pas seulement l'Union
européenne il aussi d'autres contexte on
peut coopérer très bien je rappelais
l'ut temp maisussi je sais je vend le
conseils de sécurité pour ceux qui sont
membres permanents et aussi pour les
autres qui qui participent au au au
travaux de de l'Union je crois qu'il y a
une dernière question sur la Libye les
dossiers li bienens là euh disons que
les problèmes de la Libye c'est un c'est
c'est un pays compliqué et et il faut
les connaître disons que nous avons
heureusement ou malheureusement une
certaine expérience de relation avec la
Libye et on on croit parfois voir des
choses qui n sont pas évident et ça
amenait en fait dans les passés parfois
a de différents de de de vision avec
avec Paris entre Rome et Paris mais ça
c'est désormais vraiment du passé parce
qu' une très bon coopération comme
toujours avec Paris mais avec n'importe
quel pays ou quelle personne dans le
monde dès qu'on commence à se parler les
choses normalement vont vont s'arranger
et c'est ce qu'on a fait
avec P on spare régulièrement et
maintenant je crois qu'on a une très
bonne coopération sur la Libye dans une
vision qui est largement partagé sur C
qui qui qui peu arriver dans les pays
merci merci beaucoup monsieur
Saul merci merci pour toutes ces
questions
eu pour pour en aborder quelques-unes
tout d'abord la question
euh par rapport à au défis géopolitique
posé par la Chine et la la Russie
eu donc pour prendre la Chine tout
d'abord donc c'est euh la la vérité sur
le sur le continent africain c'est que
le la Chine est souvent perçu comme une
opportunité économique un
partenaire qui présente véritablement
des des opportunités géopolitiques pour
eux plus plutôt qu'un défi euh je suis
plutôt d'accord avec mon collègue
italien euh notre approche par rapport à
la Chine c'est de rendre de de de
d'avoir un dialogue très franc avec la
Chine sur tous les enjeux internationaux
y compris leur approche euh en Afrique
ça fait partie de des contacts que nous
avons avec la Chine mais ensuite
exactement comme comme l'a dit euh
monsieur cachio de de faire une
proposition britannique ou européenne
qui est plus fiable plus attractive plus
cohérente plus convaincante pour nos nos
nos partenaires africains et ensuite
c'est c'est à de choisir euh et on est
franc avec eux que s'il préfèrent de de
suivre l'approche proposée par la Chine
il y aura des ça ça implique certains
choix ça implique certaines conséquences
mais c'est à eux de les de les
assumer mais notre but en terme de
d'offre de financement d'investissement
de de d'approche de
transparence et basé sur le le respect
mutuel que nous avons avec nos
partenaires africains c'est de c'est de
leur encourager à faire à faire un autre
choix
c'est je bascule maintenant sur le la
question russe qui c'est aussi soulevé
et qui est lie lié intimement à la
question sur la la lutte
informationnelle de
Monsieur attendez monsieur monsieur
Plard
peut-être euh oui monsieur Plard eu
parce que soyons Fran nous parlons nous
parlons surtout dans le cadre dans ce
cadre de des efforts de désinformation
russes qui sont souvent menés par des
organisations privées telles que Wagner
h euh ces activités présentent également
évidemment des des risques
importants ce sont des informations qui
qui visent à discréditer
euh que ce soit la France d'autres
partenaires européens ou souvent aussi
les nations-
Unies tout en essayant de présenter
leurs approches et leurs opérations
comme des des
réussites donc on prend ça très au
sérieux on a une stratégie qu'on met
œuvre pour pour lutter contre ça le
premier pas c'est d'exposer au maximum
ces efforts de désinformation de de les
exposer publiquement ou si ce n'est pas
possible de les expposer en privé à nos
partenaires africains et on a on a des
capacités pour le faire on a des des
capacité très
spécifique pour nous permettre
de de de surveiller et de de de
d'exposer l'origine de certaines
certaines informations on part parle on
a euh pas seulement à nos partenaires
africains parce que c'est un risque qui
existe euh plus globalement surtout dans
les Balcans également on voit beaucoup
de désinformations russes et de menac
hybride on on appuie nos partenaires
avec des capacités locales des capacités
nationales qu'on qu'on les aide à
construire pour euh leur permettre de
surveiller et de d'agir contre ces
efforts de de désinformation et on
considère aussi l'utilisation d'autres
d'autres outils tê que les sanctions
que ce soit des sanctions individuelles
ou ou plus collectives nous avons un
dialogue très poussé avec la le
gouvernement français sur ça euh c'est
un c'était une des priorités établies en
politique étrangère et de défense par le
sommet de mars de de 2023 et nous avons
un un un un un groupe de travail
spécifique sur ce sujet euh je je
souhaite aborder maintenant la cette
question de de de la stabilisation du du
du sa des coups d'État de la question
de Monsieur jacobelli je
pense donc il est il est clair que nous
pouvons pas simplement
euh tourner le dos au SAL
eu pour prendre une statistique
frappante euh en 2022 43 % des morts
causé par
terrorisme au monde ont été ont eu lieu
dans le Sahel donc c'est un une menace
risque pour ces pays-là et qui risque
d'arriver jusqu'à nos
territoires notre
approche c'est de partenaire avec nos de
travailler avec nos partenaires
africains en particulier sur cette zone
le Nigéria et le Ghana nous avons des
équipes de de formation militaire de
formation de défense
euh sur place pour donner un appui à nos
partenaires africains dans ces pays-là
mais ce sont des avec des des des
mandats des tâches très limité
contraint et on met des des contraintes
politiques on n'est pas dans une dans
une logique d'intervention militaire
opérationnelle direct on est dans une
dans une logique de formation sur des
des éléments et des capacités que les
Africains ne peuvent pas faire
eux-mêmes et avec des des limites de
temps aussi qui sont très très
claires nous avons aussi des politiques
de dével ement très poussé dans ces
pays-là très sophistiqué et nous
travaillons également avec les
partenaires régionaux et donc dans le
cadre de par exemple de la réponse à la
crise au nigerre de l'année dernière
notre approche était de vraiment
écouter la les directives et les
approches les les analyses de la CDAO et
surtout pour nous les approches et les
l'analyse du Nigéria et de vraiment
agir à la base de de leur demande h il y
a une une question spécifique de
Monsieur saintou sur la la candidature
des de certains pays africains pour
rejoindre les
bricks certains pays de Commonwealth je
reviens à ce que je disais dans mon dans
ma présentation d'origine c'està-dire
que notre approche c'est de partenariat
et le choix celui des Africains si
certains pays africains veulent veulent
rejoindre les bricks ça c'est leur choix
c'est un choix souverain qui peut le
faire h et nous pour rejoindre leses
propos d'avant c'est de le leur proposer
un partenariat fort fiable transparent
de respect mutuel eu euh et qui ce n'est
pas un choix exclusif non plus on est on
le on on dit pas certainement pas si
vous rejoignez les bricks on ne
travaillera plus avec vous euh au
contraire notre ça nous encourage à à
renforcer ce que nous proposons
h et dans ce cadre enfin des des pays
vraiment clés pour nous en Afrique j'ai
déjà cité le Nigéria le Ghana mais le
Kenya
euh où nous avons eu cette visite d'État
du Roi Charles vraiment extrêmement
symbolique et importante pour nous mais
aussi notre coopération avec avec
l'Éthiopie
h pour aborder finalement euh je pense
le le point sur la la corruption
euh
euh de de deux éléments de réponse euh
enfin à la base que nous nous sommes
d'accord sur l'importance de lutter
contre la corruption en Afrique ça c'est
clair pour nous ça fait c'est une partie
intégrale de nos efforts de
développement donc nous avons publié à
la fin de l'année dernière un un livre
blanc sur le développement international
et on aborde cette thématique là et donc
nous avons des
programmes conséquents sur la réforme
des finances publiques en Afrique et de
la gestion des finances publiques en
Afrique qui vise
exactement cette question de la
corruption mais l'autre élément c'est
que et ça a été évoqué par plusieurs
membres du comité nous avons une
relation économique avec l'Afrique
privilégiée nous nous envisageons cette
ce sommet sur l'investissement en
Afrique que nous avons fait eu pour la
première fois en 2020 ce ce dialogue
économique que nous avons avec l'Afrique
nous permet aussi d'aborder ces
thématiqu dans un contexte où nous
expliquons et généralement les leaders
africains sont d'accord que la lutte
contre la corruption est non seulement
essentiel pour leur société mais pour la
croissance économique et donc pour leur
secteur privé et l'avenir de leur pays
sur le sur le plan purement économique
euh et c'est un moyen c'est un un moyen
d'aborder cette question qui est souvent
plus efficace que leur leur parler
sûrement de la corruption comme un un
problème une problématique politique ou
sociétale voilà je je pense avoir abordé
les questions principales mais à
disposition bien sûr bien écoutez merci
à tous les trois pour ces réponses aux
orateurs de groupe nous avons quatre
questions complémentaires la parole est
à Brigitte
Klinker merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse particulièrement au
docteur
Cheffer nous l'avons entendu et je vous
remercie tous pour pour vos
interventions notre engagement à toutous
c'est important sur le continent
africain notamment pour lutter contre
l'influence de la Russie et de la Chine
pour assurer la paix et la
sécurité l'Allemagne a décidé de de
s'engager de manière significative vous
avez évoqué la stratégie
franco-allemande et européenne de
renouvellement des relations avec
l'Afrique quelle est selon vous monsieur
Cheffer la place de la diplomatie
parlementaire et en particulier comment
selon vous l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande peut y contribuer merci
merci la parole est à Mélanie
tomin merci Messieurs les Présidents
Messieurs les Ambassadeurs ma première
j'ai deux questions ma première question
s'adresse à Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
Cassio euh vous vous avez abordé dans
votre intervention assez longuement le
plan
matthi ainsi que le le contenu de ces
accords je voulais savoir plus
précisément quel changement de paradigme
ces accords engendront-il dans les
relations entre l'Italie et le continent
africain et quelles sont les attentes du
Parlement italien en la matière puisque
c'est lui qui a donner son accord euh
d'autre part j'avais une deuxième
question
euh à l'intention du ministre conseiller
saoul concernant le Royaume-Uni euh que
traduit politiquement la suppression du
département du développement
international et notamment sa fusion au
Bureau des Affaires étrangères et du
conells qui euh euh est survenu en 2020
le Royaume-Uni a-t-il fait le choix à
travers cette fusion de se détourner de
l'enjeu du développement en Afrique euh
donc est-ce une décision qui a un impact
fort en la matière je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Jacqueline Maquet
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour vos
interventions ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur saoul je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur le sommet sur
l'investissement prévu à Londres en
avril 2024 cette initiative témoigne de
l'engagement du Royaume-Uni à renforcer
ses liens économiques avec le continent
africain dans ce contexte j'aimerais
savoir comment le gouvernement
britannique envisage-t-il de concilier
ses objectifs économiques en Afrique
avec les besoins de développement des
pays africains
et comment cette stratégie s'intègre
dans le cadre plus large de la politique
étrangère britannique post brexit merci
merci et enfin s'il y a pas d'autres
question la parole est à Franck Giletti
merci monsieur le Président messieurs ma
question désolé de not the list
s'adresse aussi à Monsieur conseil
ministre en octobre et novembre 2023 Sa
Majesté le Roi Charles I s'est rendu au
Kenya pour une visite de 3 jours
soulignant ainsi les liens anciens qui
unissent votre pays et ce
dernier le Kenya membre du Commonwealth
depuis 1963 est en effet l'un des
principaux partenaires commerciaux de
Londres et de nombreuses entreprise
britanniques on suit ainsi s implanté
avec succès on comprend alors tout
l'intérêt de la relation bilatérale mise
en lumière par la visite du roi h
j'aimerais donc vous interroger sur l'un
des aspects de cette coopération à
savoir la coopération militaire le
Royaume-Uni comme la France voit à des
degrés diverses sa présence militaire
remise en cause sur le continent
africain nous ne rappellerons pas ici
malheureusement le retrait des trouses
françaises dans certains pays du Sahel
aussi monsieur euh la manière dont
Londres analyse cette situation et
compte y répondre dans les pays où le
Royaume-Uni est implanté militairement
notamment le quinya nous intéresse tout
particulièrement au moment même où la
France est en train de repenser sa
politique en Afrique merci donc pour
votre analyse sur ce point spécifique de
la contestation de la présence militaire
par des populations ou des gouvernements
locaux je vous remercie merci je ne vois
pas d'autres questions docteur schffer
vous avez la parole
euh madame la députée clinker merci de
cette
question comme dans une démocratie les
parlements sont les souverains ou les
représentants des des des souverains
bien moi en tant que humble représentant
du gouvernement n'osera jamais vous
faire des propositions sur
l'agenda de votre coopération bilatérale
avec l'Allemagne bien sûr mais je suis
assez convaincu que si
vous preniez la décision en tant
que en tant que Français parlementaire
français allemand d'aborder le sujet de
l'Afrique de simuler je crois que
surtout le gouvernement allemand le
veillerait avec beaucoup de
bienveillance et je crois que c'est même
c'est même important parce que nous
avons des valeurs apporté à tout le
monde y compris à l'Afrique
et peut-être la valeur la plus
importante de de tout
c'est notre démocratie et la défense de
notre démocratie on donc toutes les tous
les principes français et globaux de
montusqueu de la séparation des pouvoirs
et le fait que ne ce sont pas seulement
les gouvernements qui règnent et les
parlements qui suivent mais peut-être au
contraire avec nos nos histoires nos
philosophies tout à fait différentes
j'abuse monsieur le Président cette
cette possibilité pour rajouter encore
quelque chose à la question des des
poches de sang si vous me le permettez
Monsieur le Député parce que parce que
j'aimerais bien vous rappeler
qu'effectivement entre les armées
allemandes et françaises il y a depuis à
peu près 10 ans un accord sur l'échange
de sang et que je peux vous assurer que
malheureuse heureusement ça n''est pas
été nécessaire en vue de de de ne pas
avoir vu des des des interventions
militaires ou des conflits qui ont
nécessaire qui ont fait nécessaire des
du du son mais je peux vous assurer que
dans le cas où ça aurait été nécessaire
et bien du son aurait été sur
place merci beaucoup pour cette réponse
et je rappelle que dans le cadre des
Rencontres de Saint-Denis il a été
décidé d'organiser des Assises de la
diplomatie parlementaire et que la date
est en cours de fixation entre la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
le président du du Sénat mais on peut
s'attendre à ce que ces assises aient
lieu dans les prochains praine semaine
et donc ça sera l'occasion d'aborder C
ces sujets et notamment de la place que
pourrait jouer l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande les groupes d'amitié où
les échanges également entre les
commissions pour l'Italie monsieur
Cachou vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président merci madame la
députée tin pour pour cette question
donc je crois que pour résumer dans son
slogan si vous voule les plein mat c'est
la question d'un partenariat qui soit
stratégique paritaire est équitable
c'est-à-dire dans les passé on a
toujours on toujours bougé entre deux
manière de voir la relation avec
l'Afrique on on voit ça en terme
d'exploitation qui peut-être plus ou
moins nuancé les investissements les les
relations commerciales mais à la fin on
on on on a ça dans la tête ou en terme
d'aide au développement et là aussi
l'aide au développement n'est pas
seulement le les la coopération au
développement mais il y a aussi les
investissements les institutions
financières internationales mais on on
on a plutôt ça dans la tête quand on
pense à l'Afrique pour nous la question
c'est de passer un N un nouvel un
nouveau paradigme comme vous le disait
et euh de dire on a des défis que on ne
peut que auxquels on on ne peut que
faire face ensemble si on parle du
changement climatique ça c'est un défi
pour l'Afrique comme il est pour pour
l'Europe si on parle de l'énergie de
comment euh et aussi utiliser
l'énergie l'innovation de l'énergie pour
faire face au au changement climatique
euh voilà la question des
infrastructures ce sont des questions où
nous sommes ensemble avec
l'Afrique les problèmes de d'améliorer
la production de l'électricité en
Afrique c'est un problème pas seulement
pour l'Afrique c'est un problème aussi
pour l'Italie pour l'Europe pour nous
tous donc voilà c'est ça l'esprit de euh
commencer à penser que les problèmes
sont communs les solutions doivent être
communes et il faut les débattre avec
les les pays intéressés parce que c'est
pas qu'on peut imposer une solution nous
avons des idées qui qu'on va discuter la
semaine prochaine dans dans les les
sommets avec les pays de l'Afrique mais
évidemment ce sera exactement de ces
sommets qu'on on sortira avec des idées
plus précises sur ce qu'on qu'on pourra
faire
voilà merci beaucoup et enfin il y avait
plusieurs questions qui vous étent
adressé monsieur Saou notamment sur le
les sujets du développement et du forum
pour l'investissement et de votre
présence militaire également merci
beaucoup j'aiété gâté dans cette
dernière tournée de question euh mais je
c'est un compliment pour la politique
étrangère britannique et j'en je le je
le redirai à mes collègues allemands
italiens que j'ai eu trois questions
dans cette euh dernière partie h donc
euh pour retourner aux choses sérieuses
euh cette question
eu madame
tomin si je me trompe pas sur le le fait
que nous nous ayons fusionné le
ministère des Affaires étrangères et euh
pardon madame excusez-moi h et euh et le
le le ministère pour le l'aide au
développement h donc h
euh je tout d'abord ce n'est pas du tout
une question de tourner nos dos à
l'Afrique de de ou de un changement de
priorité au contraire ça met l'aide au
développement au centre de notre
politique internationale donc ce n'est
ce n'est plus que la l'aide au
développement est un axe parallèle de
not travail le développement est intégré
à chaque élément et à chaque
politique élément de politique
internationale du
Royaume-Uni nous nous organisons
maintenant avec cette fusion pour avoir
un un ex un effet maximal sur nos
intérêts nos valeurs nos priorités
d'ailleurs nous nous sommes désormais
organisés beaucoup plus comme la France
où l'Agence France développement est en
fait partie du du ministère de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères donc si si
vous voulez on a une approche un peu
plus française qu'on l'avait auparavant
et je vous explique pourquoi c'est utile
sur sur un en donner des exemples très
concrets il y a 5 ans vous faites un un
déplacement à au
vous aurez un représentant de l'aide au
développement britannique avec un bureau
Desf dement International Development
séparé de l'ambassade dans ce cas ça
serait une haute commission britannique
avec un séparé de de
l'ambassade vous avez vraiment deux deux
intervenants britanniques sur place avec
des relations des des des capacités du
financement et on se coordonnait bien
sûr beaucoup sur place dans ce genre de
pays mais avoir l'aide au développement
intégré au sein de notre nos efforts
diplomatiques et pour pour nous une
approche plus cohérente sur le long
terme surtout dans un cadre
où la croissance économique est de plus
en plus liée c'est particulièrement de
cas en Afrique à la sécurité la
stabilité le changement climatique la
résilience des états pendant que le les
crises humanitaires sont plus que jamais
eu
enclenché par par des questions de
conflit ou de d'insécurité les liens
sont réels donc là on a on a fait une
fusion une réorganisation ministérielle
mais qui correspond vraiment à la
situation sur le terrain les besoins du
terrain et qui nous permet d'être plus
efficace ensuite et je je si vous avez
le temps je vous conseillerai vraiment
de lire ce ce livre blanc qu'on a publié
à la fin de l'année dernière White Paper
on international development qui
vraiment met à jour notre notre approche
de développp internationale de façon
très très très globale très
compréhensive
ensuite sur le la question du sommet euh
de sur l'investissement euh donc on a
fait ce sommet si je me rappelle bien
pour la première fois en en 2020 euh et
ça ça soulligne l'intérêt que nous avons
pour renforcer faire évoluer nos liens
économiques avec le continent africain
euh et ça et et là le but de de la
conférence de de cette année la date
n'est pas encore fixée euh c'est
d'approfondir nos partenariats euh
modernes d'investissement de stimuler la
croissance et la prospérité des États
africains en intégrant le privé euh de
plus en plus dans ce dans cet échange h
et donc est-ce que ça est-ce qu'il y a
un conflit ou une tension entre nos nos
priorités économiques et de
développement non euh parce que le le
développement du secteur privé en
Afrique est est absolument crucial pour
la croissance économique durable euh du
continent
h ensuite dernièrement pour pour aborder
cette question sur le Kenya et je je
comprends tout à fait monsieur l'intérêt
que vous avez pour
euh pour cette
euh notre approche puisque c'est c'est
évidemment en discussion au sein du
gouvernement français
h pour vous décrire très brièvement
notre approche h nous avons plusieurs
outils sur place en Afrique dont deux eu
au Kenya au Kenya nous avons une une
unité qui s'appelle The British Army
training unit Kenya qui est une unité
qui nous permet de faire du de la
formation de nos forces dans dans le
contexte africain donc ça c'est ça nous
permet vraiment de de de renforcer nos
capacités nationales mais nous le
faisons en Afrique et ensuite nous avons
the British peace support team East
Africa donc ça c'est une
équipe qui est dirigée si je me trompe
pas je regarde mon collègue derrière moi
mais par un un général de brigade
britannique qui fait de la de la
formation de
du capacity
building pas uniquement pour le Kenya
mais pour plusieurs pays africains qui
le qui nous le sollicite qui nous le
demande et là le but c'est vraiment de
préparer les Africains au mieux à
participer aux missions de maintien de
la paix que ce soit des missions de de
l'Union africaine ou des missions de
l'ONU nous avons
ensuite un un une organisation similaire
dans l'Afrique de l'Ouest qui est basée
au Nigéria St
euh team West Africa et comme je l'ai je
l'ai évoqué nous faisons aussi des
interventions à petite échelle au Ghana
et tout ça c'est vraiment à la demande
de ces pays-là on est on est vraiment en
appui pas dans un un rôle de
leadership à disposition pour échanger
en plus de détails séparément si ça
pourrait vous être utile merci bien et
bien écoutez merci beaucoup merci à
Pierre Alexandre Anglade à nouveau pour
cette audition commune merci aux membres
de la commission des affaires europénes
et merci à tous les trois pour ces
échanges qui non seulement éclairent
utilement notre cycle de travaux sur
l'Afrique mais je crois qu'titue
également une bonne introduction à nos
au développement de nos relation
parlementaires international au travers
des déplacements qu'on aura l'occasion
d'avoir dans les prochaines semaines mes
chers collègues je vous donne
rendez-vous mercredi prochain pour
l'audition notamment du chef
d'état-major des armées bonne journée à
tous